foreign
to our next question from Heidi hello my
name is Heidi from O'Fallon Missouri our
daughter who is in her third year of
college moved back home after three
years of apartment living
and we have all her stuff in the garage
and in the basement in boxes and bags
I'd like to know what is the best way to
start with her going through all of her
things to determine what to keep or sell
or donate
well I think we start with something
called the No Junk rule you can download
our free minimalist rulebook it's called
16 rules for living with less but these
aren't really rules we tricked you
these are tools or boundaries that Ryan
and I came up with throughout the years
and of course on the private podcast we
come up with new rules all the time not
that you should Implement these rules
but for really mechanical things like
this where it's you're talking about
getting rid of clutter I would start
with the No Junk rule everything you own
including all of this junk or things
that you perceive to be junk
everything you own can fit one of three
piles it's either essential it's
non-essential but value-adding or it's
junk the first category is essential
everyone has the same Essentials
basically food shelter clothing now they
look different you know Ryan wears
different clothes for me is black shirts
different from my black shirt which is
the only essential shirt that's right uh
but food clothing shelter they all look
different for everyone but the same
fundamentals right the same sort of
foundation education vocation
Transportation all looks different for
people but these are Essentials for most
people the non-essentials these are
things that add value to your life that
make life more enjoyable I don't have to
own a couch but I get value from it I
don't have to own a coffee table but I
enjoy setting my coffee on my coffee
table and so I own a coffee table no
problem with that right I don't have to
have a a bed frame I could have the
mattress on the floor but I enjoy having
the bed frame the way it looks and the
functionality of it so there are things
I could live without but they add value
to my life unfortunately most of the
things we own
are clutter core they're junk right it's
all the stuff that actually gets in the
way of the things that we can enjoy and
so I would look at everything and place
it in one of three piles and be really
really honest because Ryan when you used
to do mentoring people would tell you
that all these things are essential in
their home sure but there were things
they'd ever used they were like
potentially essential and it's like
that's not even non-essential but
value-adding it's something that is some
hypothetical value that you're not
getting from the thing at all yeah and
so the thing I'll say to Heidi is that
I would do that but I also have some
sort of deadline a deadline is a type of
boundary in a way right it creates
urgency and that urgency is necessary
for letting go because if you don't have
the urgency you'll still have the
anxiety
and you'll be stressed out by the things
but you won't ever feel compelled to
actually let it go because it's a low
level anxiety and so you hold on to
those things hoping that maybe one day
something will magically happen and
you'll let go of those things but if you
set a deadline you say at the end of
this month you have 30 days we're going
to sort through this together I'm going
to support you in this but I'm not going
to do it for you man that's a beautiful
place to start that's good yeah I mean
Heidi unfortunately you didn't do this
on purpose but unfortunately you you did
not set up a boundary with your daughter
in the sense of uh clear yeah just clear
clear boundaries um what you did is you
were like you can have the basement and
you can have this other room and that
was her boundary and so yeah I agree
with you Josh like she's gotta find a
way to work with her daughter to find
some new boundaries and you know Heidi
the best way to approach this and this
goes for Jessica as well for the last
question like instead of going to
someone and say hey do this for me find
a way to say do it for us and and that's
how you can enroll someone instead of
just saying here's my problem that I
have with you and here's what I need you
to do uh it's more about going to them
and saying hey I really could use your
help on something and and kind of
approach it from that aspect because
that is going to
um that's just going to enroll someone a
lot more to help you than kind of
telling them what they're doing wrong
that you want them to change
Heidi one thing I love about the spirit
of your question is that I can feel you
wrestling with it in a way that signals
a lot of graciousness that you have
towards your daughter because you could
just flex your power and authority in
this situation if you are the one who's
letting her live with you you could just
say I want this stuff out of here and I
want it now and it's so easy to lead
with flexing but the thing about flexing
is once you go that once you go down
that path it changes the dynamic of the
relationship forever you might have the
right to flex but when you exercise that
right boy does it change things and so I
appreciate that you have resisted that
tendency to flex and you're wrestling
with this saying how can I go about this
in a way that creates a win for
everybody in a way that feels good and
doesn't require a fight
what I would suggest is something along
the following lines I use three
statements number one here's what I need
number two here's the concern I have
about what I need number three here's my
question for you
here's what I need you can say to your
daughter something like
I need to feel good about the space that
I live in and it's very important to me
that everywhere I'm going there's not a
whole lot of clutter that's what I need
here's my concern about what I need I'm
worried that my need might impose on you
in a way that takes away value from you
I'm worried that my demands on you would
cause you to go without the things that
you need so here's my question for you
what's the best way for the both of us
to get what we want what's the best way
for me to meet my need to declutter my
home and for you to meet your need of
hanging on to the essentials and if I
feel like I need more space or I need
you to get rid of some stuff what's the
best way for us to go about that now
you're putting it all on the table
you're being honest but you're not
antagonizing your daughter and you're
also not taking on the burden of
figuring her out for yourself doing all
the thinking for yourself and you're
having her communicate with you it's
usually a lot easier to get people's
cooperation when you approach things
with that kind of energy behind it and
for all the people on YouTube that's
gonna be like no I would just tell her
her stuff's gotta go I respect the fact
that you already know that and that
you're choosing to go about this in a
way so that you and your daughter can be
able to laugh and have a good time after
the conversation is over and I respect
that approach
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free